KEVIN, WELCOME BACK. WHAT'S
GOING ON, MIKE? GLAD TO BE
HERE. OH, GREAT TO TALK TO
ALWAYS LOOK FORWARD TO
TALKING TO YOU AFTER THE
DRAFT. THIS YEAR, THOUGH.
DIFFERENT THAN USUAL. CAN YOU
THE NON SCOUTS? THE
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND? JUST WHAT
A CHALLENGE THIS YEAR WAS IN
COMPARISON TO A NORMAL YEAR.
WHEN YOU LOOK BACK ON 2019,
WE HAD A NORMAL FALL. WE HAD
A COMBINE AND OF COURSE, THE
PANDEMIC IT. AND WE HAD A
SHUTDOWN. THE PRO DAYS THIS
YEAR. WE WERE ABLE TO GET
OUT IN THE FALL. I'LL BE IT
IN A DIFFERENT FORMAT, WHICH
WAS FINE. WE COULD GET AT
LEAST TO GET TO SEE SOME LIVE
LOOKS, WE DIDN'T HAVE A
COMBINE BUT WE HAD PRO DAYS
AND THE PRO DAYS WERE
RESTRICTED ON THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE THAT COULD GO AND YOUR
ABILITY TO ACCESS THE PLAYER.
SO IT'S BEEN
DIFFERENT. BUT WE WERE ABLE
TO GET ALL THE INFORMATION
THAT WE COULD AND HOPEFULLY
WE USED IT IN A GOOD MANNER.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN FOR A TEAM
TO NOT BE ABLE TO HAVE THE
PRIVATE WORKOUTS? IT'S NOW
BEEN TWO YEARS WITHOUT THOSE.
YEAH YOU KNOW WHAT I REALLY
CAN'T ANSWER THAT BECAUSE WE
DON'T SUBSCRIBE TO THE
PRIVATE WORKOUTS. IN OUR
OPINION, IF A PLAYER
PARTICIPATES IN THE COMBINE
AND HE GOES TO HIS PRO DAY
AND PARTICIPATES THERE THAT'S
IT OUT FROM THOSE TWO
EXPOSURES AND WE'LL PROBABLY
NOT GOOD ENOUGH AT WHAT WE DO.
SO WE'VE NEVER USED THE
PRIVATE WORKOUTS AND WE NEVER
WILL EITHER. WELL, YOU
MANAGED TO FIGURE OUT BASED
UPON THE AVAILABLE
INFORMATION. THAT NOT J.
HARRIS, WAS THE PICK IN ROUND
ONE. I LOVE THE FACT THAT IT
WAS 49 YEARS. AFTER FRANCO
WAS THE FIRST ROUND RUNNING
BACK, AND IT'S CLEARLY AN
AREA OF NEED. WHAT IS IT THAT
ATTRACTED YOU TO THE ALABAMA
RUNNING BACK NAGI IS A, YOU
KNOW, HE'S A
WELL, ROUNDED RUNNING BACK TO
PLAYED IN A PRO SYSTEM, HE
MADE NFL RUNS ROUTINELY AND
HE COULD ALSO PLAY IN THE
PASSING GAME. BOTH OF THE
RECEIVER AND A BLOCKER. HE'S
BASICALLY A THREE DOWN BACK
AT, IN AN NFL OR COMING FROM
AN NFL LIKE SYSTEM AND PLUG
IT INTO A SIMILAR TYPE SYSTEM.
SO HE MADE NFL RUNS AT THE
COLLEGIATE LEVEL, HE DID IT
AT A HIGH LEVEL, HE HELPED
A NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP, SO
HOPEFULLY HE CAN HELP US WIN
SOME GAMES.
YOU KNOW, A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO, NICK SABAN THE ALABAMA
COACH TOLD BILL BELICHICK AND
A DOCUMENTARY ON HBO THAT
HE'S SURPRISED HOW FEW
COACHES AND SCOUTS ACTUALLY
CALL HIM. DID YOU GUYS TAP
INTO NICK SABAN'S KNOWLEDGE
EXPERTISE AS RELATES TO NOT
HARRIS. NO WE DIDN'T. I MEAN
WE HAVE YOU KNOW WE HAVE
SEVERAL CONTEXTS THERE IF WE
YOU KNOW USUALLY WE WON'T GET
INTO CONTACT AND A HEAD
COACH AND LESS THERE'S REALLY
ONE SPECIFIC QUESTION. I MEAN
THOSE GUYS
I HAVE TO DEAL WITH, YOU KNOW,
SEVERAL PLAYERS AND HUNDREDS
OF DIFFERENT TYPES OF CALLS.
YOU KNOW, THAT'S ONE PART OF
THEIR JOB AND I'M SURE THEY
WOULD HELP IF NEED BE BUT
WE'RE VERY SENSITIVE TO THE
HEAD COACHES AVAILABILITY,
AND TIME AND AND
OCCASIONALLY WE WILL REACH
OUT. BUT MOST OFTEN WE DO NOT
WHEN PEOPLE TRY TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT WENT WRONG WITH THE
STEELERS RUNNING GAME LAST
YEAR. THERE ARE DIFFERENT
REASONS DIFFERENT FACTORS.
THAT COULD BE POINTED TO THE
FACT THAT YOU USED YOUR FIRST
ROUND PICK ON A RUNNING BACK.
I THINK WOULD CAUSE AN
WELL, THEY
MUST NOT HAVE FELT GOOD
ENOUGH ABOUT THE GUYS THEY
HAD. SO THEY UPGRADED THEIR
IS THAT A FAIR ASSESSMENT OF
WHAT WAS WRONG LAST YEAR?
THAT YOU JUST NEEDED TO
UPGRADE THE QUALITY OF THE
PLAYERS. WELL, WE THANK YOU
KNOW, ANYTIME YOU TALK ABOUT
THE RUNNING GAME, YOU TALK
ABOUT THE RUNNING GAME, YOU
TALK ABOUT WHAT STARTS UP
FRONT. YOU TALK ABOUT YOUR
RECEIVERS BEING ABLE TO GET
OPEN, YOUR QUARTERBACK BEING
ABLE TO COMPLETE PASSES,
HAVING A WELL-ROUNDED
PASSING GAME THAT OPENS UP
THINGS FOR THE RUNNING BACK,
ADDITION TO HAVING A CAPABLE
RUNNER, WE HAD CAPABLE
RUNNERS LAST
YEAR, OUR OFFENSIVE LINE WENT
THROUGH A TRANSITION AND YOU
KNOW, HOPEFULLY WE'RE GOING
TO COME OUT THE OTHER SIDE
OF IT BUT IT'S COMPREHENSIVE.
AND WHEN WE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE A GUY
LIKE NA ZHI, WE THINK THAT
WILL HELP SIGNIFICANTLY WITH
OUR RUN GAME. JEROME BETTIS
HAD SOME COMMENTS TO ADD
BRUSCHETTA OF THE ATHLETIC
LAST YEAR THAT RESONATED WITH
ME BETTER SAID THE RUNNING
GAME IS SOMETHING THAT STARTS
IN TRAINING CAMP. THE
COMMITMENTS IN TRAINING CAMP
BUT MINDSET, THE BLOCKING
EVERYTHING THAT GOES ALONG
WITH IT, IF YOU DON'T HAVE IT
AND IT'S HARD TO PICK IT UP,
HALFWAY THROUGH THE SEASON.
WAS THAT PART OF THE PROBLEM
LAST YEAR THAT MAYBE THE
COMMITMENT WASN'T THERE FROM
THE OUTSET OF TRAINING CAMP
FOR WHATEVER REASON? NO I
MEAN HONESTLY YOU KNOW GOING
INTO THE SEASON WE WERE VERY
SUCCESSFUL WE GOT TO AN 11
AND OH MARC DOING WHAT WE
WERE DOING. AND THEN WE
DIDN'T, I MEAN, WE DIDN'T WE
DIDN'T PLAY WELL DOWN THE
STRETCH. I'LL BE AT THE
RUNNING GAME NOT BEING UP TO
PAR THE PASSING GAME, NOT
BEING UP TO PAR THE PASSING
THE DEFENSE NOT BEING WHAT IT
WAS. SO WE WERE SUCCESSFUL
OFFENSIVE LY ALBEIT WITHOUT
A REAL DEVASTATING RUN GAME
AND IN THE END IT WAS THE IT
ENDED UP BEING THE WORST IN
THE LEAGUE. AND THAT, OF
COURSE, IS PART OF, YOU KNOW,
OUR FAILURES DOWN THE STRETCH.
BUT ULTIMATELY IT'S A
THREE-PHASE THING. AND WE
HAVE TO IMPROVE IN EVERY
PHASE. THERE ARE MANY KEVIN
WHO BELIEVE THAT. NO TEAM
SHOULD TAKE A RUNNING BACK
IN ROUND ONE THAT THEY CAN
BEGOTTEN, UNDRAFTED, LIKE AN
ARIAN FOSTER OR MOST RECENTLY
A JAMES ROBINSON. WHAT TRAITS
DO YOU NEED TO SEE BEFORE YOU
WILL PUT A RUNNING BACKS NAME
ON A CARD IN ROUND ONE AS
OPPOSED TO ADDRESSING ANOTHER
AREA NEAT? YEAH I MEAN I
DON'T BUY INTO THAT, WE DON'T
INTO THAT BELIEF AT
AT ALL. AGAIN, IF A PLAYER
WE THINK IS A VERY GOOD
PLAYER AT THE COLLEGIATE
LEVEL AND WE THINK YOU CAN BE
A VERY GOOD PLAYER AT THE NFL
NFL LEVEL REGARDLESS OF THE
POSITION.
POSITION, I WILL TAKE THEM IN
THAT FIRST ROUND IF HE'S
AVAILABLE. I'VE SAID IT
BEFORE, BEEN AROUND TO HALL
OF FAME RUNNING BACKS THAT
WERE BOTH FIRST-ROUND PICKS
AND JEROME BETTIS AND BARRY
SANDERS. AND, YOU KNOW, WE
WERE FORTUNATE ON EACH TEAM
TO HAVE THOSE PEOPLE WITH US.
SO WE DON'T BUY INTO THAT.
YOU KNOW, THE ONLY TRUE VALUE
I SEARCHED FOR IS, HOW MANY
GAMES CAN WE WIN? AND CAN
THESE PLAYERS HELPED US WIN.
THE SUPER BOWL IS USING A
FIRST ROUND, PICK ON A
RUNNING BACK AND INDICATION
THAT THIS GUY'S GOING TO COME
HE'S GOING TO BE ON THE FIELD.
EVERY DAMN. WE'RE BASICALLY
GOING TO USE THIS GUY BECAUSE
WE INVESTED SO MUCH IN
GETTING IT. NOW, USUALLY,
WITH YOUR FIRST ROUND PICK,
YOU KNOW, IN THE YOUR SECOND,
SOMETIMES, YOUR THIRD
ROUNDERS, YOU WANT THEM TO BE
THREE DOWN BACKS AND, YOU
KNOW, THAT'LL BE UP TO COACH
TOMLIN AND HIS STAFF AS TO
HOW QUICKLY NAUSEA GETS ON
THE FIELD AND HOW MUCH THEY
USE THEM. BUT WE DO KNOW THAT
HE'S CAPABLE OF PLAYING ALL
THREE DOWNS AND THAT'LL JUST
BE WORKED OUT THROUGHOUT THE
SUMMER. ONE OF THE WORST
KEPT SECRETS
IT'S LEADING INTO THE DRAFT,
WAS THE IDEA THAT THE
STEELERS WERE LOOKING RUNNING.
BACK A LOT OF MOCK. DRAFTS
THE STEELERS LENGTH, THE
HOW NERVOUS WERE YOU IS
DEPICTS WERE COMING OFF THE
BOARD THAT SOMEONE WAS
POTENTIALLY GOING TO JUMP.
THE STEELERS AT 24 AND GET
HIM BEFORE YOU COULD. YEAH,
THERE'S REALLY NOTHING WE
COULD DO. I MEAN, WE KNEW WE
WEREN'T TRAINED UP. WE NEEDED
ALL OF OUR DRAFT CAPITAL
THROUGHOUT THE DRAFT, AND WE
MADE A DECISION. WE WON'T BE
TRADING UP. WE ALSO
MADE A DECISION THAT HAVE
CERTAIN PLAYERS ARE THERE. WE
WON'T TRADE AWAY FROM THEM
AND NAGI WAS ONE OF THOSE
PLAYERS. SO REALLY WE LAY IT
OUT AND WE KNOW WHAT ORDER WE
WOULD TAKE 24 PLAYERS THAT
COULD GET TO US AND IN
THE ORDER THAT WE WOULD TAKE
THEM. SO WE JUST WAIT IT OUT.
AND IF WE HAVE TO TRADE UP
LIKE WE DIDN'T COUPLE YEARS
FOR DEVIN BUSH THAT MAYBE WE
DO IT OR TRADE BACK, BUT WE
JUST WAITED IT OUT. AND IF
WE WERE CERTAIN ABOUT THAT
ONE OF THE BIG QUESTIONS FOR
THE STEELERS OFFSEASON, AND
IT SEEMS LIKE IT WAS RESOLVED
SO LONG AGO BECAUSE SO MUCH
HAS HAPPENED IN THE LEAGUE
OVER THE LAST THREE MONTHS
IS IT THE TEAM'S ANTICIPATION
THAT IT'S ONE MORE YEAR WITH
BIG BEN OR IS IT? LET'S JUST
GET THROUGH THIS YEAR AND SEE
WHERE WE GO FROM HERE. YEAH,
I THINK BEN'S MINDSET IS,
FOCUSED ON 2021 AS WE ALL ARE
AND I THINK WE ALL GO INTO IT
AND WE FOCUS NOW WE SEE WHERE
THINGS LEAD BUT BEYOND THAT,
OF US KNOW. AND OBVIOUSLY
BENDS AT THE IN THE BACK END
DISAPPOINTED, THE WAY WE
AND, YOU KNOW, THE SHORTLY
AFTER THE END OF THE SEASON,
HE CAME TO US AND SAID,
LISTEN, I WANT I WANT TO BE
BACK, YOU KNOW, OF COURSE, WE
HAD TO WORK OUT SOME THINGS
CONTRACTUALLY AND HONESTLY,
HE SET OFF A NICE LITTLE
SURGE FOR US BECAUSE WE HAD
SET OFF A NICE LITTLE SURGE
FOR US BECAUSE WE HAD SEVERAL
PLAYERS THAT WERE ABLE TO
COME BACK TO US. BUT BEEN LED
THE WAY BY TAKING THAT PAY
CUT AND YOU KNOW THE STEELERS
STRIKE ME IS ONE OF THE
TEAMS THAT WHEN THE
ORGANIZATION SAYS WE'RE
TRYING TO WIN THE SUPER BOWL
EVERY YEAR, IT'S NOT JUST A
GIMMICK TO SELL TICKETS. IT'S
NOT JUST AN UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE CHANCES OF WINNING
IT ANY YEAR OR SLIM IT SEEMS
TO ME LIKE THE STEELERS GO
ALL IN EVERY YEAR WAS THE
ROETHLISBERGER SIGNING THAT
INDICATION, THAT WITHOUT
QUESTION THAT'S THE GOAL.
THIS YEAR THAT WE THINK WE
HAVE THE TALENT, WE THINK WE
CAN ADDRESS THE ISSUES FROM
LAST SEASON AND GET OVER THE
HUMP IN 2021. WELL WE KNOW I
MEAN THE GOAL WILL NEVER
CHANGE. I MEAN YOU KNOW THE
THE YOU'RE EITHER YOU'RE
EITHER WINNING A SUPER BOWL.
IF YOU DON'T YOU FAILED AND
WE KNOW THAT HAVING BEEN ON
21 GIVES US A BETTER CHANCE
THAN NOT HAVING BEEN ON OUR
TEAM BECAUSE HE IS HE STILL A
SIGNIFICANT PLAYER, WE THINK
HE CAN STILL PLAY AT A HIGH
LEVEL AND HOPEFULLY WE'VE GOT
THE TALENT AROUND HIM TO HELP
HIM DO THAT. HOW DOES HAVING
A 17TH GAME IN THE REGULAR
SEASON THIS YEAR? AFFECT YOUR
JOB AS THE PERSON RESPONSIBLE
FOR PICKING THE PLAYERS
GETTING THEM ON THE ROSTER
KNOWING, WHICH GUYS ARE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO PLAY 17 AND
WHAT PLANS YOU HAVE TO HAVE
IN PLACE IN THE EVENT THAT
SOME CAN'T, YOU KNOW WHAT?
THAT'S
IT'S AN UNKNOWN TO ALL OF US.
WE KNOW WHAT 16 IS LIKE WE
KNOW WHAT A FORD PREGAME
PRESEASON IS LIKE LEADING
INTO 16 BUT NONE OF US KNOW
WHAT A THREE-GAME PRESEASON
WILL BE LIKE LEAVING INTO 17.
YOU KNOW, WE PLAY FOR BECAUSE
OF THE HALL OF FAME GAME THIS
YEAR, BUT I THINK WE'LL ALL
BE LEARNING THAT HOW TO MANAGE
THIS, BUT IT'LL BE IT'S
FOR EVERYBODY. THE STEELERS
ARE A MODEL OF CONSISTENCY
AND CONTINUITY IN THE
FELL. THAT'S NO SURPRISE.
MIKE TOMLIN GOT A CONTRACT
EXTENSION EARLIER. THIS
OFFSEASON THERE'S STILL A
GROUP OF FANS THAT GET RILED
UP EASILY WHEN THERE'S
ADVERSITY AND THEY WANT TO
CHANGE COACHES AND THAT
SURPRISES ME BECAUSE SO MANY
COACHES AROUND THE LEAGUE
HAVE IMMENSE RESPECT FOR
WHAT MY COMMENT HAS BEEN ABLE
TO DO. WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THE
FANS OUT THERE? WHO JUST SEEM
TO HAVE THIS QUICK TRIGGER
THAT WHEN THINGS AREN'T GOING
WELL? WE GOT TO CHANGE THE
COACH IN PITTSBURGH WELL AND
TERRITORY THAT WE LIVE IN AND
HONESTLY, MIKE, IT'S OUR OWN
EXPECTATIONS ARE MUCH HIGHER
THAN ANYTHING FROM THE
OUTSIDE. AS YOU MENTIONED IT
BEFORE, SUPER BOWLS ARE ALL
WE MEASURE OURSELVES BY SO
WHEN WE COME UP SHORT WE WE
FEEL WE FEEL
AND WE DON'T FEEL GOOD FOR A
ANOTHER CHANCE TO TRY IT
AGAIN. SO ANY ANY EXTERNAL
TYPE PRESSURE REALLY DOESN'T
BOTHER US AS MUCH AS THE
INTERNAL PRESSURES THAT WE
PUT ON OURSELVES TO PUT THE
BEST TEAM OUT THERE TO TRY TO
WIN A SUPER BOWL. HOW
SURPRISED WERE YOU THAT THE
WAY THE DOMINOES FELL JUJU
SMITH, SCHUSTER ENDED UP,
STICKING AROUND, IN
PITTSBURGH, FOR AT LEAST.
ANOTHER YEAR. WE KNEW OUR WE
GOING INTO THIS OFFSEASON
WITH THE, YOU KNOW,
THE CAP?
GOING DOWN. IT WAS GOING TO
BE A DIFFICULT ROAD FOR A LOT
OF FREE AGENTS AND WE FELT
THAT THERE WAS PROBABLY GOING
TO BE A LOT OF SHORT TERM
DEALS BECAUSE PLAYERS WOULD
WANT TO GET BACK OUT THERE
YOU KNOW, AND TEST THE
MARKET AGAIN NEXT YEAR, WHEN
THE CAP GOES UP SO WE ALWAYS
LEFT THE DOOR OPEN. YOU KNOW,
WE ENCOURAGED OUR PLAYERS.
LOOK, FIND OUT WHAT'S OUT
THERE. DO THE BEST YOU CAN
AND THEN, YOU KNOW, CALL US
KEEP US IN THE LOOP AND MAYBE
WE CAN FIGURE SOMETHING OUT.
SO, IN JUJU'S CASE,
IT WAS GREAT THAT, YOU KNOW,
WE WERE ABLE TO KEEP HIM WITH
US. BECAUSE AS WE MENTIONED
EARLIER, HE CAN HELP US AND
HE CAN HELP BEN TRY TO WIN A
SUPER BOWL, ONE OF THE BIG
DRAWBACKS FOR LAST YEAR, FROM
STEELERS PERSPECTIVES, HARDLY
ANY FANS AT THE GAMES BECAUSE
OF THE LOCAL RULES AND
REGULATIONS. DO YOU KNOW
ANYTHING AT THIS POINT ABOUT
WHAT LOCALLY AND ACROSS THE
STATE IN PENNSYLVANIA? THE
RULES ARE GOING TO BE FOR FAN
ATTENDANCE OR AT LEAST THE
EXPECTATION FOR FAN
ATTENDANCE WHEN SEPTEMBER
NOW, WE'RE ALL JUST VERY
HOPEFUL THAT AGAIN, THINGS
RETURN TO NORMAL, NOT JUST
FOR OUR FANS, OR OUR GAME, OR
OR HOCKEY. YOU KNOW,
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A LOT MORE
IMPORTANT LIFE ISSUES THAT
NEED TO BE, YOU KNOW,
SOLIDIFIED AS WELL. SO WE'LL
ALWAYS, YOU KNOW, ADHERE TO
THE PROTOCOLS. WE KEEP OUR
FINGERS CROSSED THAT WE CAN
GET BACK THE FULL STADIUMS
AND YOU KNOW TWO MORE YOU
KNOW, IT'S A MORE VIABLE
LIVELY EVENT
AND YOU KNOW,
AND IF WE CAN ACHIEVE THAT
WITHOUT ENDANGERING OUR FANS
OR OUR PLAYERS AND GREAT, I
SPOKE WITH JUJU SMITH
SCHUSTER RECENTLY, AND I
ASKED HIM ABOUT HIS COMMENT
FROM, FROM, BEFORE THE
PLAYOFF GAME AGAINST
CLEVELAND BROWNS IS THE
BROWNS AND THE LESSONS. HE'S
LEARNED FROM THAT WHAT
LESSONS IF ANY AND HE WAS
VERY CANDID WITH ME THAT HE
UNDERSTANDS THAT IT MOTIVATED
THE BROWNS WHEN HE SAID WHAT,
HE SAID, WHAT LESSONS DO YOU
WANT THE PLAYERS TO LEARN
FROM THAT MOMENT? AND THE
WAYS THAT AN OPPONENT,
CAN GET ITSELF, RILED UP A
LITTLE BIT MORE BASED ON THE
THINGS THAT ARE SAID IN THE
MEDIA. WELL, AGAIN, ALL I,
WE CAN LOOK AT IS THE RESULT
OF THE GAME. YOU KNOW,
CLEVELAND PLAYED A GREAT
GAME AGAINST US IN THE
PLAYOFFS AND THEY WON AND WE
WENT HOME. SO WE ALWAYS WILL
LOOK BACK ON. WHAT DIDN'T WE
DO? CORRECT TO GET THEM TO
RESULT THAT WE WANTED. SO WE
ALL LEARN FROM EVERY ASPECT
OF THAT, AND, YOU KNOW, JEW
CAN SPEAK FOR HIMSELF ON THAT
MATTER. BUT AGAIN, WE ALWAYS
LOOK AT EACH OTHER. WE LOOK
AT OURSELVES
SAY WHAT DIDN'T WHAT COULD WE
DO? BETTER. SO THEY'RE NOT
HAVE THE SAME RESULT SCHEDULE.
RELEASE IS COMING NEXT
WEDNESDAY. WHAT'S THE FIRST
THING? YOU? LOOK AT WHEN THE
STEELERS SCHEDULE DROPS
HONESTLY, IT'S JUST WHO'S
NUMBER ONE. WHO IS OPENING
UP WITH BEYOND THAT? NONE OF
US. CAN WE CAN'T FOCUS ON
ANYTHING ELSE BUT THE OPENER.
ALL GOING TO PLAY EIGHT HOME
PLAY AT AWAY GAMES, THAT
BOTHER US. HOW THERE'S HOW
I HAVE NO CONTROL OVER SO
NUMBER ONE, AND LET'S START S
FOCUSING ON THAT OPENING GAME.
AN